now from a big premiere to a huge
series finale as post bids farewell
after three seasons
this is it
this is the end the critically acclaimed
show which focused on the lives of trans
women and gay men of color during the
eighth epidemic
held a finale celebration at the fyc
panel on saturday in pasadena california
stars billy porter mj rodriguez
co-creators ryan murphy
steven canals and two huge super fans
elton john and david furnish
all attended the drive-in event this
series touched me more than any other
series because
of the journey that these people are on
i mean i am
electra i
[Music]
while of course there were laughs the
final episode also brought tears as
billy's character lost his battle
with aids i'm not ready to lose you pray
[Music]
i'm not ready to let go a poignant
moment for the show and billy as just
last month he opened up for the first
time about his real-life battle with hiv
after being diagnosed 14 years ago at
the event david furnish noted that while
there's been progress in treating hiv
and aids
the fight isn't over the medicines are
so effective now that we're not seeing
people sick and dying
thank god they work really really well
but we have frightening statistics
like in america 50 percent of all
gay black men in america will contract
hiv in their lifetime
and with the medicines that we have
today if everybody knew about hiv
knew they were at risk and had access to
testing and treatment
we could stop this disease dead in its
tracks